we're playing mahjong
that Eliza that means play motion so
mahjong is a really old game that
originated in China it's one of the best
games that I've ever played
it looks like chess and checkers and
cards combined I've never even seen it
played but I know it's supposed to be
really fun and there's a lot of yelling
involved if you're losing yes I really
don't know what this game is I've only
seen it played in like Chinese dramas
the best way to start learning is to
understand what the tiles are get three
types of tiles you have suits honors and
bonus okay so usually we play on a
square table because it's just easier so
now we're going to watch them and
everyone turn them over onto their green
so watch that the grandmas aunts
everyone will play this around the table
the kids will hang out and they would
just like gossip over stuff yeah it was
like part of growing up
there was like five sets of mahjong and
my grandma's house and she like invited
every human over to play everyone has a
version of mahjong this is gonna be like
pretty basic like Chinese version it's
just pretty much like a matching game it
is a matching game isn't like that one
game [ __ ] so I take two you take two
huh you take two
get faster guys quick status yep
everyone's fast in this game yeah I got
it okay so you can either choose what do
I do now is good I feel like I'm getting
in touch with my Asian heritage and I am
winning at it so Mallory when did you
start playing
I learned probably early on like seven
for my grandma and my mom would talk
about it and say like this is this
that's that you have to match them and
it's like a matching game but I never
played probably until I was like in
college welcome
my grandma died so then I just I like
mahjong kind of left with her oh wait we
we we we did I win no it has to be palm
Kong or chow and then one pair also you
should say mahjong mojo it's like you
know so basically you have like one left
last hand to play yeah
wait wait you really if I have through
what they say yeah you have my John wait
does that mean you want so fun cuz I
almost won not gonna lie it was hard but
it was fun yeah how can you say that you
did a bad job when you get three wide
right I definitely feel more connected
with my like Chinese side because I
remember learning these Chinese
characters when I was in school and it
totally reminded me of that stuff I had
a great time I would love to invite
friends over gossip plate yeah it's just
like all hang out and like play this
yeah I'm down alcohol Halle Berry you
gave me these